وهذه صور لاستهداف من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لمعسكر جماليه قرب مدرسه تؤوي
عددا من
النازحين الان تشتعل النيران في هذه
المناطق كما
تشاهدون يبدو انه ا استدا فات
[موسيقى]
الان ك تشاهدون هذه
النيران لمتابعه المشهد في شمال غزه عموما
بما فيها التطورات الاخيره ينضم الينا من
مستشفى الشفاء شمال مدينه غزه مراسل
الجزيره اسماعيل الغول اهلا بك اسماعيل
نقف معك على المشهد في ظل هذا القصف
المتواصل ل للجيش الاسرائيلي على مناطق في
جباليا وايضا في مناطق اخرى في
الشمال نعم لم يتوقف القصف الاسرائيلي على
المناطق الشماليه لمدينه غزه بالتحديد
شمال وادي قطاع غزه هذه المناطق التي
يمارس اي جيش الاحتلال عملياته منذ ما
يزيد عن 50 يوما في هذه المناطق حتى هذه
اللحظه يفشل في بسط السيطره الكامله على
هذه المناطق في الساعات الاخيره قوات
الاحتلال قصفت قرب مدرسه اووي النازحين في
شمال قطاع غزه بالاضافه الى استمرار القصف
المدفعي على منطقه جباليه البلد ومنطقه
مخيم جباليه ه هاتين المنطقتين تعرضا لقصف
عنيف وقصف عشوائي مما ادى لوقوع الكثير من
الاصابات في تلك المنطقه علما ان هذه
المنطقه لا تحتوي على اي من المشاف الطبيه
بالاضافه الى اي نقاط طبيه ايه تعمل على
عمليات كبيره او عميقه او التعامل مع
اصابات البالغه في هذه المناطق مما يؤد
الى استشهاد الكثير من الفلسطينيين
متاثرين بجراحهم بالانتقال الى مدينه غزه
بالتحديد الى المناطق الشماليه الغربيه
لمدينه غزه قوات الاحتلال عملت على نسف
منطقه بشكل كامل في منطقه دوار فلسطين
وهذه المنطقه دمرت بشكل كبير جدا وهذا ما
احدثه الانفجار العنيف الذي هز اركان
مدينه غزه ومختلف المناطق في مدينه غزه
اما بالانتقال للمناطق الشماليه الشرقيه
فتحاول قوات الاحتلال الدخول الى حي
المناره هذا الحي الذي وقفت على مشارف منذ
ما يزيد عن 40 يوما وتحول قوات الاحتلال
تتقدم من منطقه حي الشيخ رضوان الى منطقه
الجلاء نزولا الى حي المناره والان قوات
الاحتلال تمارس الضغط العنيف في تلك
المنطقه بالقصف المدفعي والاسلحه والاسلحه
الرشاشه بالاضافه الى القصف من الطيران
الحربي واتت شهادات من تلك المنطقه ان
كثير من المواطنين قصفت بيوتهم فوق رؤوسهم
وكثير من الاشلاء اسفل الانقاظ ولم يستطيع
التعامل اي مواطن ما في تلك المنطقه بسبب
القصف العنيف انتقال ال المناطق الشرقيه
الشماليه هذه المنطقه التي تحتوي على
منطقه حي الزرقاء ومنطقه حي الدرج ومنطقه
حي التفاح تحاول قوات الاحتلال التقدم من
المناطق
الشرقيه الشرقيه الوسطى لمدينه غزه الى
المناطق الشرقيه الشماليه وايضا هذه
المناطق تواجه قوات الاحتلال بها مواجهات
ضاريه انتقالا الى منطقه حي الشجاعيه وهذه
المناطق حتى هذه اللحظه
كما يصرح تصرح قوات الاحتلال تواجه ضغطا
عنيفا في هذه المنطقه ومقاومه شرسه من
مختلف الفصائل الفلسطينيه وعلى راسها
كتائب القسام التي عملت على
قنص بعض الجنود وتفجير الدبابات بالاضافه
الى المواجهات بالاسلحه الرشاشه وقذائف ال
105 وقذائف الياسين هذه المناطق انتقالا
الى منطقه حي اليرموك التي تراجعت قوات
الاحتلال بها هذه المنطقه التي تتوسط
مدينه غزه وتراجعت قوات الاحتلال بها الى
مناطق شماليه غربيه من مدينه غزه المناطق
الشماليه الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه وهي منطقه
حي الصبر افاد بعض المواطنين ان هناك ايضا
تراجع لقوات الاحتلال لكن لازالت
المواجهات الضاريه في منطقه حي الزيتون
وهذه المناطق التي تواجه ضغطا عنيفا من
المقاومه منذ ايام طويله اما عن الوضع
الانساني في مدينه غزه لازال الوضع
الانساني كارثي وتطالب الطواقم الطبيه من
يحتوي دمه او فصيله دمه اي نيكف او اي اي
موجب او اي سالب بالتوجه الى مستشفى
الشفاء لانقاذ حياه المرضى وبتخطيط مرضى
التلاسيميا الذين يعانون من فقر حاد في
الدم وهذه هي المناش التي وصلت خلال
الساعات الاخيره بالاضافه الى الاصابات
الكثيره التي بحاجه الى اسعاف من وحدات دم
واطقم طبيه وبالاضافه الى معدات طبيه متق
معدات طبيه لازمه مثل تشغيل غرف العمليات
في مستشفى الشفاء شكرا جزيلا لك مراسل
الجزيره اسماعيل الغول